So today we're gonna talk about how
Dynamic pricing can be implemented
um before we start few words about me so
I'm working at flixbus since almost
three years as data engineer and my main
skills are information retrieval Big
Data algorithms and data structure
and this Summit cross I didn't engineer
I just went there to climb it's one of
the highest mountain in Switzerland so
when I'm
not working I'm usually in the mountains
so what we're going to talk today
so first we will give a brief
introduction about what is dynamic
pricing
why it's so important for the companies
and what are the biggest challenges when
you have to implement something like
that and then we will see how we step by
step move closer to something like Real
Time pricing
and when it comes to Dynamic pricing
every seconds count
so how many of you have heard about
Daniel pricing
oh that's quite a lot so it's going to
be interesting talk and how many of you
have worked with standard pricing in
their projects nice nice to see that a
lot of people have uh already done
something we can talk after the talk
so yeah what is standard pricing so it's
a strategy that used to set the prices
for the same product and this price can
depend on different criterias uh for
example the demand at different time and
it can be depending on different types
of people so just to give you some
example uh here's an example from Uber
so when you are booking a ride in Uber
it might depend on at what time you are
booking the ride and What's the total
distance of the ride and what is the
current traffic situation
also it depends on the current demand
there might be some other factors but I
just wanted to give you some examples
so let's say you are in the city center
of Munich at seven o'clock in the
evening on Friday and there is a huge
demand for for we are going around the
city
in that case what Uber does is it
increases the price and they notify also
the users and the drivers about this
increase in the price and this way
um if the user is willing to pay high
price higher prices this will bring them
more profit at the same time some users
might not afford this price and they
prefer to wait for the cheaper prices
and this way they manage the demand also
they notify the drivers that there is a
huge demand in certain areas so they
might be traveling to that area and in
test a in that way they also manage the
demand because they will be able to
serve more Demand with more drivers so
that's that's like a two-way benefit for
them
so let's let's see in
in these graphs how it can be useful for
the companies so if you have just one
price point as you can see in this plot
your revenue is also fixed and the
disadvantage of this approach is that
there might be some people who who could
not afford this price and they then you
could not sell your product to those
people and also maybe there were some
people who were willing to pay more
prices or higher prices but they
couldn't you couldn't get that extra
benefit from them so then there is
something where you can have multiple
price points and you can see this plot
usually the plot looks like this where
the price and the demand is uh like in
this curve and there you have multiple
price points in this way you can say see
like uh if you have um
some people who are not able to afford
that price they maybe buy your product
earlier or depending on situation when
the prices are cheaper and at the same
times there might be some user who don't
care so much about the money and you
will get more revenue from them this way
you can see there are several bands of
Revenue and your Revenue has like
suddenly increased in this way
so
that's a little introduction about the
dynamic pricing and now let's see what
are the biggest challenges when it comes
to implementing Diamond pricing so there
might be several challenges but I want
to focus on this talk mainly on two big
challenges which we found were worth
mentioning in the talk so the first one
is handling a large amount of data in
real time and the second problem is
optimizing pricing in the real time so
coming back to the first problem uh when
you have a large amount of data in real
time you can imagine if you have a very
large company like Philips bus people
are continuously booking the tickets and
this generates a lot of data in real
time
also we have a lot of we have Network
all the over the across the globe and
that's why like 24 hours we have a huge
demand and we have a lot of data
generated to uh to our system and we
should be able to uh handle this large
amount of data
and the second important factor is this
data has to be very fresh because if you
are if you are late in capturing this
data to your system you will lose
revenue for every seconds
and the third important factor is that
when you have a new company merged to
your company for example recently we
bought Greyhound and it was a big
network from them and you have to adapt
your system such that you can also
accommodate the changes from the new
company and this results in schema
changes on your system and a lot of
stuff maybe they were doing the same
things in a different way and you have
to adapt to your system according to the
requirements and the last very important
point is that your system has to be
robust so that it can handle the load in
the peak time so maybe in the mornings
there are a lot of Rights departing so
you should be able to handle this load
because every downtime to your system
will cost the money
so how we solve this is using uh Kafka
and postgres so how many of you have
already heard about Kafka
wow that's a good number and so I'm not
going to go into detail so we use Kafka
to consume different types of data so it
could be for example the pass booking
data so when user are purchase
purchasing tickets we collect this data
and then we use Kafka to consume it it
could also be a network related data for
example a bus ride some information
about the route from which it's going
through and it could also be the
information about the bus maybe how many
seats are there and so on and it could
also be a data which is coming from
different teams from machine learning
models and this data can be really
really huge on the other hand it could
also have some data which is not
changing so frequently for example the
geolocation data and this all we use
consumer group and where each topic is
dedicated for one particular topic and
then the large topic are usually divided
into several partitions so that we can
consume this data very fast in parallel
and usually the events from Kafka are
continuously persisted in our database
and most of the time one event
corresponding to the one row in our
database
and you can imagine like since there is
a continuously data coming to our
database it will explode at some point
so that's why we also have some cleanup
done regularly so we remove the past and
stale data from our database which is
not useful anymore
and last point is very important to
handle the peak load so when we have a
lot of data coming in we can use
kubernetes Auto scaling to handle this
load and keep our data fresh by the way
I forgot to mention that all our
applications are written in Python
otherwise I won't be talking here and we
use kubernetes to deploy our
applications
so I will talk a little bit more about
this horizontal Port scaling so on the
left side you can see kubuntus
configuration file and you can use a lot
of tricks to handle the peak load in
this case we use something called
horizontal pod Auto scaling which means
you can replicate your instances
depending on how much you are needs are
for example in our case we can use
something called consumer lag which
represents how far behind you are from
the current Kafka stream and this number
can give you approximately an idea about
how fresh your data is so in in this
case you can specify the number of
replicas uh maybe minimum one or three
and you can specify a Target value for
example 1 million or something like this
and based on this target value they can
replicate automatically and you will
have the desired number of instances for
your application so here you can be as
aggressive as possible so maybe you
don't want 1 million maybe you want
really really fresh data so you can just
say a very low number here and here the
number of replicas are calculated using
this formula so if you have let's say
desired number 1000 1000 and your
current consumer lag is 2000 then it
will have like two replicas or something
like this
so this is very important to keep our
Peak load in
to handle the peak load in our
application
so now it's we have the data ready we
have a very fresh data in our database
and now we are ready to optimize the
prices so there are other challenges
when it comes to optimizing the prices
in real time the first problem is
that optimizing can be very expensive
because it requires a lot of
computational efforts and resources to
perform every optimization
and you have to apply this optimization
as soon as possible
um so how we tackle this it will before
we come to that point I want to give you
a little background about how a pricing
engine can look like so here you have
there are some inputs it could be
booking data it could be the forecast
about the demand it could be it could be
some data related to the ride itself
like how many seats are there which city
pairs it's going through and so on and
then there might be some other data
which I'm not mentioning here
um
yes
so then all this go in this uh something
called pricing engine and then it will
find the optimal prices
which will bring the maximum Revenue
and you can also tune it uh to have
other desired effect maybe you want uh
to have maximize maximum load like so
that your buses are running full uh yeah
you can tune the Target and based on
that you will get the optimal prices
um
so yes so this you might have imagined
that the computational efforts are so
much and if you do it a lot of times it
will require a lot of money and also it
might be not possible so a little bit
background about the demand estimation
so when there is a right
um there is like
um you can see it's departing maybe in
somewhere in future and you can see a
lot of people actually buy tickets when
it comes to just maybe few weeks or few
days so the demand changes very fast
close to the departure and when you are
further away from the departure then the
demand stays more or less the same so
you can divide the whole time access in
several periods we call them booking
periods and these booking periods you
can assume the demand would more or less
stay the same in this booking period And
as you can see like if you go to
departure you have like very fine uh
intervals but when you are far away from
the departure you have like really huge
interval and this is because as I said
like a lot of demand changes as you
close to the departure and we received
this information over Kafka every day
it's generated by some learning models
from other team and also there might be
some cases when there was an unpredicted
event which our machine learning model
was not aware of and there is a
possibility to externally affect or
influence this demand and in that case
we also receive this immediately
so now we have the fresh data now we
have the the demand and what we can do
so the first thing we started or we
thought about was batch processing job
so let's say every day we apply the
optimization for each ride for each
booking period and let's see what
happens so if you have 1 million rights
which you want to optimize in two hours
you will have to do like 140
optimizations per second by the way
these numbers are artificial so they are
not so important
the advantage of this approach is that
it's easier to implement you can scale
it because you can have a lot of
parallel computations and it works out
offline
but there is not just a problem that you
have to perform these many optimizations
per second which is a lot of
computational effort and maybe you will
earn more Revenue but you will spend
more time spending money in AWS or
something
um so let's see what are some other
problems instead of just the
computational effort so here is the
first problem as you can see uh this uh
batch processing job let's say it starts
at 3 am in the morning and it takes uh
two hours
um then you have like uh just optimize
the price five o'clock previous day and
you have uh unoptimized price for
approximately 24 hours because at 505
there is a bubble which means that the
demand has already changed and you
should have uh optimized at this point
and the prices are already too old and
this is not the optimal prices for this
ride
um other problem is the cost
Effectiveness as you have already seen
that the demand has not changed so much
when it's very far away from future but
if you optimize everything every day it
will require a lot of wasted of
resources because most probably the
prices will not change
and the last problem with the batch
processing job is a really important one
so it's not reactive to changes so let's
say at five or five previous day they
decided to change the ride maybe they
decided to add more seats in the bus and
then you will have no chance to
identify these changes until the next
optimization comes so that's why it's uh
also a loss of revenue for us so this is
these are the some problems and we see
how we solve them by closing by moving
one step closer to the real-time
processing so here is one example where
a ride has a Time access and these
bubbles in green they show the places
where the demand actually changes and if
you have several of those let's say you
have six of those you can see all the
bubbles in the time access and each
bubble represents that these at this
point the demand will change and you
should optimize that specific ride and
if you just to these numbers of
optimization it will reduce already the
number of optimizations performed per
second for example if you have 1 million
rights it will be approximately very
less to very less than one optimization
per second
um so how can we achieve this uh let's
say you have uh this time access and you
are somewhere in this uh red place where
the current time is shown you don't have
to consider all the next optimization
time for any particular ride but just
the the next one and this way you have
only six bubbles in the time axis and
you just keep the track of these Bubbles
and when you are at particular bubble
you optimize this particular right and
then you calculate the next optimization
time and you move it to the next one
and this is just an illustration in
pictures but how can you achieve this in
computer science you can use something
called priority view how many of you
have heard about priority View
yes it's a very nice data structure
because it can do some Magics
um so it basically has two properties
one is called Heap property it's a
binary tree which is balanced and each
parent node has a priority higher than
the children and if you have some
example here for example the orange one
would be the first one and then you have
the subsequent numbers where the they
are at lower priority but the highest
one is always at the top and this is
very useful because this is exactly what
we need in our case we we want to find
out at particular time what is the
highest priority ride and you might also
want to update some of the rights and
this you can see in the right table
these operations are really really fast
like the maxim is the worst case uh is
Big O uh notation is just login which is
very fast and it can handle millions of
Rights also
just to give you uh like the big picture
is very simplified compared to what we
actually have
um so we have a Kafka consumer where we
have uh continuously data coming to our
system we store this in our database and
then we have something called Write
manager which takes this data and then
it decides the priority calculates the
next optimization time and then it also
puts in is something called redis task
queue which is an open source library
from flixbus you can check it out and
this is very useful when you have to
perform a lot of parallel computations
and this is very well documented um
and the next thing is like when you have
a lot of tasks here these pricing
engines can these pricing engines can
work in parallel so you have multiple
instances of these pricing engines
running and then these prices are
produced these optimal prices are put in
the Kafka again as a lookup table where
they can be used further
um one important point I wanted to
mention here is like I didn't mention so
far how it's reactive to changes uh to
some events for example uh maybe there
was a change in the route or maybe there
was a change in the capacity uh this is
done also in the ride manager so uh when
there is a data in coming to this right
manager it also sees uh if there was
such change and in that case it will
update the priority in such a way that
actually it re-optimize those rights
immediately and this is the the core of
this whole pipeline that actually can
handle all all the changes in real time
and in the best case uh if you have not
so much load it the prices are reflected
within seconds uh once there is a such
an event in your real time
so just to summarize uh what I uh
explained like how we saw how we can do
real-time pricing updates and how it is
reactive to different types of
activities maybe it's forecast a lot of
bookings are happening capacity updates
and so on and it's also possible to
externally influence uh in case of
unpredicted events because your models
cannot predict everything and in case of
these such cases we have possibility to
externally influence the the prices also
and it's highly scalable and robust as I
said we use kubernetes Auto scaling to
make this work
there are some links here for example
the first one is a little bit article
about how you can Implement Auto scaling
and the second one as I mentioned it's
open source Library you should check it
out and there might be some other
projects from Flix which you can also
which you might be interested also
and yeah that the last slide is about
fix like I'm really happy working with
Flix because there are a lot of creative
projects and we are also hiring so if
you are looking for new challenges in
your life join the ride
thank you so much for your talk we have
a couple of questions the first one is
particularly good the real reason why we
are here is what is the trick to buy the
bus tickets for the best price
yeah that's very interesting question I
and I knew it would be there
um so actually it's very hard to predict
even for us like when the prices will
jump because it depends on a lot of
activities and criterias but in in
general like if you buy the prices well
in advance you will have cheaper tickets
okay
um next one how do you test and compare
the business performance of different
pricing models
yes we we did some simulations uh before
we
um with our past data and we compared
the performance of different models
okay
um what algorithms are are you using to
predict the prices yeah I'm not sure if
I'm allowed to disclose this here
so you can move to the next question
um in case you're removing the past data
don't you think that this data might be
useful for continuous learning of your
machine learning models for dynamic
pricing yes so data is removed only from
our database but it can also be uh it we
store this also at some other places
where the cost is not so important or
also the performance is not so important
for example in S3 or on snowflake
okay how do you make sure that the given
price will capture the demand that is
how do you find the most optimal price
that will serve the demand yeah as I
said like it's very difficult to predict
if your prices are really optimal but
yeah we have seen some increases in
Revenue I'm not uh
sure if I can reveal the numbers but we
have seen significant increase in the
revenue with this okay
how do you identify the demand bubbles
um
I'm not sure if I'm not actually working
in the demand prediction model so I'm
not maybe the right person for this
question okay
um what's the data size you have to
store in your postgres SQL database S1
database instance sufficient or did you
have to distribute data across multiple
instances so we have a pretty big
instance in AWS and so far one database
has been sufficient to handle all the
load
um and we do a lot of tricks to optimize
the queries which we perform against the
database so it's it's so far fine but
maybe in future we will think about
further improvements if we have some
more data or we hit some bottleneck
do you use any for example rule-based
sanity checks to ensure that only
reasonable prices come out of this
optimization yes we do a lot of Sanity
checks before this data is published in
Kafka and also the teams which is taking
these prices as input they also perform
further checks on top to make sure that
our prices are good enough or this they
qualify certain minimal criterias
do you have a b testing for finding the
best price if yes how does the a b
testing framework looks like yeah again
it's something I cannot answer here
so we don't know whether it's better
ends of how your Mozilla browser yes
um do you do anything to track
competitor prices and adding it into
your models
yeah again it's a very sensitive talk
okay
um
yeah I mean they're all going to be
sensitive but I'm moving on how much
Financial impact
um are you able to generate with this
Dynamic pricing yeah it's again in the
same same category unfortunately
since I keep um
how many people are working on your
pricing pipeline
um I think we have around
um
yeah 50 to 100 people working in the
whole domain and we have divided this in
several teams maybe six seven teams okay
um why is real time not possible
I mean real time is like very difficult
but you can achieve the same results
with when you are at least like within
seconds so it's almost real time okay
um how do you deal with the current
instance shortage on cloud providers
like AWS when Auto scaling
um
yes we have Auto scaling and we have
some uh configurations where we we have
also some um
fault tolerance when it comes to like
maybe there is a breakdown or something
happens we make sure that our pipeline
starts at the same place where it
actually terminates so it actually
creates some very uh small backups in in
the system and then it starts from where
it actually left so it does not lose a
lot of info it actually does not lose
any information and then it starts again
okay
was there any crazy Dynamic pricing like
above 1K for right
I haven't seen it so far okay
um
is there a feedback loop with the
network planning
yes we have uh yeah we get information
from the network planning and um
yeah we do
communicate with them about the the
prices and optimization
but it's like uh yeah also not very
something which I cannot say clearly
here yeah
okay
um why was it necessary to build your
own priority queue that's a very good
question actually finally something I
can answer
so uh actually if you know like I
mentioned that you also have to update
the priority of certain rights maybe
there is a event which uh you yeah which
was required to change the priority and
this is not happening in default
periodical so in default priority queue
you can only remove the topmost element
or you can add a new element but you
cannot change the priority of any
particular node in the tree and that's
why we had to implement our own priority
game okay very nice and the last one was
any covert effect
um yes there was some problem like a
shortage of network but it didn't affect
so much that
um that we we were like so much affected
by this
okay then thank you so much for your
presentation for your answers and we
look forward for the more sensitive
answers next year yeah thank you thanks
a lot
foreign